This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全、但在这里可以畅所欲言的坦诚对话，而你的倾听对象是一位经验丰富的持证专业人士。有多少男人披着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须去硬扛，来《艰难成长的教训》
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例只有这么点。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everyone. Welcome back to the podcast for
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一面成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是TWA%，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到播客
a new episode, a new week, new listeners, old listeners. Great to have you here to discuss a really interesting topic today, one that has been on my mind for a while, and I thought it would be interesting, just for my own personal knowledge, but for maybe anyone who's listening, to do a little bit of a deep dive into this topic. And we have just one major question to answer today. One question I really want to get to the bottom of, and it's how does taking hormonal birth control in our 20s influence our psychological experience and well-being, and at the end of the day, is it worth it? Should we be given more information when we make that decision? And what do we need to know about the interactions between taking hormonal birth control and our general well-being
收听新的一集、新的一周，新老听众们。很高兴你们今天能来探讨一个非常有趣的话题，这个话题我一直在思考，而且我想不仅为了我个人的知识储备，也为了任何正在收听的听众，深入研究这个话题会很有意思。今天我们只有一个主要问题要回答。一个我真正想要探究到底的问题，那就是：在我们20多岁时服用激素类避孕药，是如何影响我们的心理体验和幸福感的？归根结底，这样做值得吗？在我们做出这个决定时，是否应该被告知更多信息？我们需要了解哪些关于服用激素类避孕药与我们整体幸福感之间的相互作用，
and how we experience the world and our emotional reactions in our 20s. So a super interesting topic, super interesting to research. There's so many different thoughts, and it was a bit of an effort to discern fact from fiction. I think any time we talk about women's reproductive health, it gets a little bit messy. There's often a lot of subjective information that we have to overlook. So, yeah, there'll be heaps of really nuanced discussions in this episode that I hope. you enjoy. And thank you to my wonderful friends, Meg, and also Meg, yes, two lovely Megs for suggesting this topic or some version of it. I have really wanted to discuss this on the
以及在我们20多岁时，我们如何体验世界和我们的情绪反应。所以这是一个超级有趣的话题，研究起来也非常有意思。有那么多不同的想法，要从事实中辨别出虚构的内容也花了一番力气。我认为每当我们谈论女性生殖健康时，事情总会变得有点混乱。我们常常需要忽略许多主观信息。所以，是的，这集节目中会有大量非常细致入微的讨论，希望你们会喜欢。谢谢我 maravilhoso 的朋友梅格，还有梅格，是的，两个可爱的梅格建议了这个话题或它的某个版本。我一直很想在
pod for some time, but like I said, it did require a little bit of research, and I think it might be slightly controversial in the eyes of some, so I really wanted to tread with some care, but still do it justice. I think personally from the rhetoric I see online, and even in my daily life, birth control can come with a lot of opinions attached to it, as do many topics related to female reproduction and female bodies. So in planning this episode, I really wanted to dispel some myths and discuss it from the perspective that we always take, which is a psychological one. So let's jump straight in and yeah, kind of get to the bottom really, I don't know, just have a nice discussion about what there is to consider when we start taking hormonal birth control.
播客上讨论这个话题已经有一段时间了，但正如我所说，这确实需要做一点研究，而且在某些人眼里，它可能稍具争议，所以我真的很想小心翼翼地涉足，但又要做到公正对待。我个人认为，从我在网络上甚至日常生活中看到的言论来看，避孕药往往伴随着很多观点，就像许多与女性生殖和女性身体相关的话题一样。所以在策划这一集时，我真的很想消除一些迷思，并从我们一贯采用的视角——也就是心理学的视角——来讨论它。所以让我们直接切入正题，好吧，真正弄个水落石出，我不知道，只是对当我们开始服用激素类避孕药时需要考虑的事情进行一次不错的讨论。
I think we need to be honest. Most of us are having sex in our 20s, maybe casually or in a serious or committed relationship, but sex and intimacy do form a big element of most of our lives in our 20s as we test relationships, we figure out what we want, and quite frankly, just enjoy ourselves and have fun. But fun and exploration and pleasure aren't the only parts of sex. So as it's probably clear by now, in this episode, we're going to talk about birth control for people, mainly for people with a vagina. But if you are someone who identifies as male and who has sex with women or those with a vagina, this episode is still very much for you. It is a neutral responsibility, both parties' responsibility, to be concerned with.
我觉得我们需要诚实。我们大多数人在20多岁时都有性生活，也许是随意的，也许是在一段严肃或坚定的关系中，但性和亲密关系确实构成了我们20多岁时大多数人大生活的重要部分，我们在其中考验关系，弄清楚自己想要什么，坦白说，就是享受生活，自得其乐。但快乐、探索和愉悦并不是性生活仅有的部分。正如现在可能已经很清楚的那样，在本期节目中，我们将讨论针对人们（主要是针对有阴道的人）的避孕措施。但如果你是一个认同自己是男性、且与女性或有阴道的人发生性关系的人，这一集依然非常适合你。这是双方都应承担的中立责任，是双方都应关注的
reproductive health and the possibility of not only pregnancy but also STDs when we are engaging in consensual sex and the use of hormonal birth control for those who are having sex who are sexually active is obviously a big thing to be considered but it should not be a simple consideration and I think too often when women go to their doctors at you know 16 17 18 and whenever they become sexually active and ask about birth control or are asked about whether they'd considered it by their doctor or what method they are on, the first thing that's often suggested is hormonal birth control, normally the pill, and one that is estrogen-based.
生殖健康以及在进行双方同意的性行为时不仅要考虑怀孕的可能性，还要考虑性传播疾病（STD）的可能性，而对于有性行为的人来说，使用激素类避孕药显然是一个需要重大考量的问题，但它不应该是一个简单的考量。我认为，很多时候，当女性在16、17、18岁左右（也就是无论她们何时开始有性生活时）去看医生，询问有关避孕的问题，或者被医生询问是否考虑过避孕或目前在使用什么方法时，通常首先建议的都是激素类避孕药，通常是避孕丸，而且是以雌激素为主的避孕药。
It's easy, it's effective, it's cheap, and I think that's often all that we want, and we might not ask many further questions, especially since we accept what our doctors have to say, we trust them and considering that the pill is so socially accepted and prevalent, we probably know someone who is already on it, especially if you're a young woman in their late teens or early 20s. But part of the conversation that is normally not had in that kind of medical context is the physical and psychological, emotional, mental side effects that can last even beyond when you do seek alternative methods, when you change birth control or stop it all together. And that's what we're discussing today. How does the use of hormonal birth
它很简便、有效、便宜，而且我认为这往往是我们所求的全部，我们可能不会问太多进一步的问题，尤其是因为我们接受医生的话，我们信任他们，考虑到避孕丸在社会上如此被接受且十分普遍，我们身边可能就有人在服用，特别是如果你是一个处于十几岁末或二十岁初的年轻女性。但这种医疗背景下通常不会进行的对话的一部分，是那些甚至在你寻求替代方法、更换避孕药或彻底停药之后仍会持续存在的身体、心理、情绪和精神方面的副作用。这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。在我们20多岁时，使用激素类避孕
control in our 20s shape our psychological experiences and our well-being? How does it impact our relationship to our bodies? I know this is said all the time, but like the natural cycle for a woman, you know, follows a lot of cycles in nature. Is that something that's important to consider interrupting that cycle might remove how in touch we are with the natural. cycle of our hormones and the natural cycle of the planets. I know it sounds a little bit wishy-washy, but this was some of the stuff that came up when I was researching this and put all the cards on the table. I think it's really important to consider. So hopefully we learned something today. I definitely did, so stick around. So before we discuss the psychology of birth
药是如何塑造我们的心理体验和幸福感的？它如何影响我们与身体的关系？我知道这种说法经常被提及，但就像女性的自然周期一样，你知道，它遵循着自然界中的许多循环。这是一个重要的考虑因素吗？即打断这个周期可能会让我们不再那么契合荷尔蒙的自然周期以及行星的自然周期。我知道这听起来有点虚无缥缈，但这确实是我在研究这个话题时出现的一些内容，要把所有牌都摊开来看。我认为考虑这一点真的很重要。所以希望我们今天能有所收获。我确实学到了很多，所以请继续收听。所以在我们讨论避孕的心理学之前，
control, specifically birth control that uses hormones like pregestone and estrogen, mainly the daily pill is kind of the focus of this episode. Let's do a bit of a history lesson and explain how it is that hormonal birth control methods came to be and how they work. So before we had this simple and easy form of reproductive control, the daily pill, modern forms of birth control like latex condoms and IUDs and of course birth control pills, they're all still relatively new in the context of, you know, general overall human history. But there were things that came before it. And records from, you know, ancient Greece and Egypt show that I think control over reproduction
特别是使用孕激素和雌激素等荷尔蒙的避孕措施（本集的重点主要是每日口服避孕丸），让我们先做一点历史课，解释一下激素类避孕方法是如何诞生的以及它们是如何运作的。因此，在我们拥有这种简单易行的生殖控制形式（每日口服避孕丸）之前，现代避孕方法（如乳胶安全套、宫内节育器，当然还有避孕丸）在人类整体历史的语境下，其实都还相对较新。但在它之前也出现过一些东西。古希腊和埃及的记录表明，我认为对生殖的控制
has been a concern for, you know, pretty much as long as humans have been reproducing, being able to have control over women's bodies, either for women or, I guess, four women, or by others that are invested in women's reproductive health has been something that's been on everyone's minds for a while and it is actually a big part of history. I think we often tend to think that only in the last 100 years have methods become available for women to have control over when they want to have children if they want to fall pregnant. But early birth control methods from around the world have been around for some time. And I had a little look into what some of these included because I thought it would be
一直是人类的关注点，几乎伴随着人类繁衍的历史一样久远。能够控制女性的身体，无论是为了女性，还是我猜为了女性，或者由那些投资于女性生殖健康的人来控制，这已经成为大家关注了一段时间的事情，它实际上是历史中很大的一部分。我们往往倾向于认为，仅仅在过去100年里，才出现了让女性能够控制自己何时想要孩子、是否想怀孕的方法。但来自世界各地的早期避孕方法已经存在了一段时间。我稍微了解了一下其中包含的一些内容，因为我认为这会
really interesting. But of course, we had condoms. Often they were made from animal blooders or linen or silk or plants. I don't know if that sounds particularly pleasant. But yeah, I guess they had to do what they had to do. Another really interesting one was spermicides. So spermicides essentially stop the sperm from reaching an egg by killing the sperm or by making it unable to swim. And there were these really interesting kind of archaeological studies and historical studies that found that some ancient cultures used to make spermicides out of acacia and honey and rock salt and sometimes even like animal feces and yet also doesn't sound particularly pleasant. Some of the other ones that were really interesting were sponges like made of moss or bamboo and they would often be soaked in
非常有趣。但当然，我们有避孕套。它们通常由动物膀胱、亚麻、丝绸或植物制成。我不知道这听起来是不是特别愉快。不过，是的，我想他们当时也是别无选择。另一个非常有趣的避孕方法是杀精剂。杀精剂本质上是通过杀死精子或使其无法游动来阻止精子到达卵子。有一些非常有趣的考古学和历史研究发现，一些古代文化曾经用金合欢、蜂蜜、岩盐甚至有时用动物粪便来制作杀精剂，这听起来同样也不是特别愉快。其他一些非常有趣的方法包括用苔藓或竹子制成的海绵，它们通常会浸泡在
oil or vinegar or lemon juice like substances that were below. leave to slow down or weaken sperm. And there were even early kind of suggestions of there being oral contraceptives often used by nobility, including queen aunt. So she used to take lead, yep, and other toxic metals mixed with things like pomegranate seeds and papaya and sylophium and blue cohesion and things like that and would consume them on a daily or before she was like having sex to prevent herself from falling pregnant. So these don't sound like particularly fun methods of birth control. And not only were they not very effective, they could often be very dangerous and sometimes
油、醋或柠檬汁等物质中，人们认为这些物质可以减缓或削弱精子。甚至还有早期关于口服避孕药的说法，通常由王室成员使用，包括安女王。她过去常服用铅——是的，还有其他有毒金属与石榴籽、木瓜、西尔菲姆（silphium）、蓝升麻（blue cohosh）等东西混合在一起——并会每天或在发生性行为之前食用它们，以防止自己怀孕。所以这些听起来都不是特别有趣的避孕方法。而且它们不仅不是很有效，还往往非常危险，有时
it was the choice of men whether they were used. So cheap, easy, accessible birth control that is within the woman's control, such as the oral contraceptive, has obviously now been championed as a massive step. forward for women's rights. Big move from, you know, stuffing sponges in lemon juice up there, not to be crude, but that kind of makes sense. Oral contraceptive has really changed the kind of landscape around reproductive health. It's now the personal, consistent choice of women over whether they want to have children or fall pregnant and allows them to kind of control the size of their families. I think we hear all these stories about people having 10, 15 children before,
是否使用这些方法完全取决于男人的选择。因此，廉价、简便、易得且在女性掌控之中的避孕方法（例如口服避孕药）现在显然被奉为女性权利的一大巨大飞跃。与把浸透柠檬汁的海绵塞进那个部位相比（免得太粗俗，但那种做法确实能说得通），这是一个巨大的进步。口服避孕药确实改变了生殖健康周围的格局。它现在成了女性对于自己是否想要孩子或怀孕的个人、持续的选择，并允许她们控制家庭的规模。我想我们经常听到这样的故事：在
hormonal birth control was invented. And that sounds also pretty unpleasant. And I think before the creation of the daily pill, women and people with a vagina were often kind of subject to the whims of their uterus and their cycles and didn't really have the same level of control over their reproductive systems. It also has to be said that it's a woman's choice often whether she consumes the pill. And it's completely within her control when she takes it. if she wants to take it in most cases.
激素避孕发明之前，人们有10、15个孩子。听起来也挺难受的。而且我认为在发明每日口服避孕丸之前，女性和有阴道的人往往受制于她们的子宫和周期，对自己的生殖系统并没有真正达到同等水平的控制。还必须指出的是，女性通常是自己选择是否服用避孕药。在大多数情况下，她完全可以控制自己何时服用、是否想要服用。
And that is something that has only come up recently before it was kind of the men's decision whether they wanted to control the size of their families or prevent someone from falling pregnant. So hormonal birth control, particularly the daily pill, it was pioneered by four people in particular. And although they have contributed greatly to reproductive rights for women, their personal beliefs and values don't really pay. paint them as kind of the feminist icons, people serving heroes that the history books often call them. There are some details that are definitely overlooked that kind of murky the waters a little bit. So firstly, there was this activist and sex educator. Her name was Margaret Sanger.
而这是最近才出现的情况，在此之前，决定是否控制家庭规模或防止某人怀孕完全是男人的决定。因此，激素类避孕药，特别是每日口服避孕丸，是由四个人率先开创的。尽管他们为女性的生殖权利做出了巨大贡献，但他们的个人信仰和价值观并没有把他们描绘成历史书上经常称赞的那种女权主义偶像、服务人民的英雄。有一些细节确实被忽视了，这让情况变得有点混浊。首先，有一位活动家和性教育家。她的名字叫玛格丽特·桑格（Margaret Sanger）。
And she is often called the founder or creator of modern day birth control. If you look up, who is the creator of, you know, the pill, her name will probably often come up. And it will say something around the fact that she was this huge advocate, she was this feminist, she was pro-sex, that all sounds really lovely, right? Sounds like something we really get behind. But what is not often known is that is kind of the way that she was able to catalyze or activate science to pursue this new technology. And that was by appealing to the eugenics movement to advocate for birth control. Yes, eugenics. For those of you who don't know what eugenics is, I'm sure you've seen it in the history books in one form or another. It is the study of how to
她通常被称为现代避孕的奠基人或创造者。如果你去查“谁是避孕丸的创造者”，她的名字很可能会经常出现。而且它会说到诸如她是一个巨大的倡导者、女权主义者、支持性解放之类的事，这听起来真的很美好，对吧？听起来像是我们真的很支持的事情。但人们不常了解的是，这正是她得以催化或激活科学以追求这一新技术的方式。那就是通过呼吁优生学运动来倡导避孕。是的，优生学。对于你们中不知道什么是优生学的人，我确信你们在历史书中以这样或那样的形式见过它。它是关于如何
kind of arrange reproduction within a human population to increase the incurrence of heritable characteristics that we see as desirable. Okay, so if that sounds off and a little bit gross, you would be right. Other supporters of the eugenics movement include Hitler, for example, in his extermination of Jewish people and other populations. This can kind of be credited with thoughts and ideas that he gathered from the eugenic movement and the idea that we want to be able to arrange the human population to be desirable. Some white supremacy groups also still of big proponents of eugenics. So it doesn't sound like a particularly kind and moral group to be a part of. But it also does make sense that the people who would want to eliminate undesirable characteristics and genes
在人类种群中安排生殖以增加我们认为可取的遗传特征出现的频率的研究。好吧，如果这听起来令人反感又有点恶心，那你猜对了。优生学运动的其他支持者还包括希特勒，例如他在对犹太人和其他人口的大屠杀中。这可以说归功于他从优生运动中收集的想法和观点，以及我们希望能够安排人类种群使其变得可取的理念。一些白人至上主义团体至今仍然是优生学的大力支持者。所以这听起来并不是一个特别善良和有道德的群体。但它也确实说得通：那些想要消除不可取特征和基因的人，
would be the first ones in support of a form of medicine that allows them to control in some ways who and who cannot have children. So that was kind of the group that Margaret was appealing to. there is the jury is still out of the whether she just saw it as a means to an end and just wanted funding to pursue this new technology and she thought it would really put the power back in the hands of women but that's kind of still up for debate and I think it's a very dark history when we think about how common hormonal birth control and the daily pill is now and how kind of unconsciously a lot of women tend to take it without really knowing the origin stories of this of this birth control method. But there are other pioneers of kind of modern day hormonal birth control and these include
将是第一批支持某种医药形式的人，这种医药形式让他们能够在某种程度上控制谁可以生孩子、谁不能生孩子。所以这就是玛格丽特所诉求的群体。关于她是否仅仅将之视为达到目的的手段，并只是想要资金来追求这项新技术，且认为这确实能把权力重新交到女性手中，目前仍无定论，但这还在争论中。我认为，当我们想到激素类避孕药和每日口服避孕丸如今有多么普遍，以及许多女性在并不真正了解这种避孕方法起源故事的情况下往往多么无意识地服用它时，这是一段非常黑暗的历史。但现代激素类避孕药还有其他先驱，其中包括
the biologist and scientist Gregory Pinkers, the suffragist and she was also a millionaire. Catherine McCommerich, she was an heiress and is kind of credited with giving a lot of the financial backing to some of the first early clinical trials. And then we have a Catholic physician and a gynecologist, also a scientist whose name was John Rocked, and he helped conduct the first clinical trials. So the research was kind of getting underway in the 40s, as scientists realized that by increasing the rates of certain hormones in primates, but also in humans, they could prevent ovulation and they could prevent people from falling pregnant. but in 1954 these two doctors, Pinkison Rock, with the backing of our friend Catherine and
生物学家和科学家格雷戈里·平克斯（Gregory Pinkers）、女权运动者（同时也是百万富翁）凯瑟琳·麦考密克（Catherine McCommerich）。她是一位女继承人，被认为资助了最初的早期临床试验的大部分资金。然后我们还有一位天主教医生、妇科医生，同时也是一名科学家，名叫约翰·罗克（John Rock），他协助进行了最初的临床试验。因此，这项研究在40年代左右拉开帷幕，当时科学家们意识到，通过提高灵长类动物以及人类体内某些荷尔蒙的水平，他们可以阻止排卵，并防止人们怀孕。
the racist Margaret, began their first trials in Massachusetts. And they were pretty small. It was only on about 50 women. And like I said, they had realized a little bit earlier that if we increased the rates of estrogen and progesterone in our bodies, the two main hormones that work on our reproductive system and within our bodies, the following effects that it would have on our internal systems and the reaction would help prevent pregnancy. So this is how the pill works. When we artificially increase the rates of estrogen and progesterone, these hormones suppress the
但在1954年，这两位医生平克斯和罗克，在我们朋友凯瑟琳和种族主义者玛格丽特的资助下，在马萨诸塞州开始了他们的第一批试验。规模相当小。只有大约50名女性。正如我所说，他们此前不久刚刚意识到，如果我们增加体内雌激素和孕激素的水平（这两种主要的荷尔蒙作用于我们的生殖系统和体内），它对内部系统产生的后续影响和反应将有助于防止怀孕。这就是避孕丸的工作原理。当我们人工提高雌激素和孕激素的水平时，这些荷尔蒙会抑制
release of a follicle stimulating hormone and the lutenizing hormone from the pituity ground in the female body. So basically, these two hormones trigger the release of estrogen from the ovaries, which in turn stimulates the release of a mature egg, which is how we fall pregnant. But if these two hormones, so the follicle stimulating and the lutanizing hormone are suppressed, the chances of ovulation and therefore fertilization by a male sperm cell are significantly reduced. Basically, it interrupts our body's signals within our normal cycle and tells the body that, you know, no, we can't get pregnant. we shouldn't release these two main hormones because we already have enough of this other hormone in the body.
女性体内垂体释放卵泡刺激素和黄体生成素。基本上，这两种荷尔蒙会触发卵巢释放雌激素，进而刺激成熟卵子的释放，这就是我们怀孕的方式。但如果这两种荷尔蒙——即卵泡刺激素和黄体生成素——被抑制，排卵的几率以及随之而来的被男性精子细胞受精的几率就会显著降低。基本上，它打断了我们身体在正常周期内的信号，并告诉身体，不，我们不能怀孕。我们不应该释放这两种主要的荷尔蒙，因为我们体内已经有足够亮的其他荷尔蒙了。
Our body is doing fine. We'll be able to fall pregnant normally. So it basically blocks our body from responding to natural cues to release an egg, meaning that no egg is released and therefore you can't get pregnant. So progression-only birth control pills, they do something a little bit different if it's just progesterone. They kind of make it difficult for sperm. to reach the egg in the event that ovulation occurs, but it has less of a direct effect on that follicle stimulating and lutenizing hormone. So it doesn't stop ovulation. It just prevents
我们的身体运转良好。我们将能够正常怀孕。因此，它基本上阻止了身体对释放卵子的自然信号做出反应，这意味着没有卵子释放，因此你无法怀孕。所以仅含孕激素的避孕丸在只有孕激素的情况下会做一点不同的事情。在发生排卵的情况下，它们会使精子难以到达卵子，但对卵泡刺激素和黄体生成素的直接影响较小。所以它不会阻止排卵。它只是阻止
kind of the sperm from getting in. So these two doctors, Rock and Pinkus, used an oral contraceptive pill, much like the ones we have today containing synthetic progesterone that they got supplied by a pharmaceutical company. And they administered it to 50, women under what they called a fertility study because at the time in the 1950s, so not even 100 years ago, not even 100 years ago, contraception was illegal in much of the United States, including in Massachusetts. So they kind of had to conduct this study on the guise of actually trying to help women fall pregnant rather than giving women the power to not do so. So this pill was taken by women for 21 days, followed by a seven-day break, and they concluded that no ovulation occurred in any of the
精子进入。所以这两位医生，罗克和平克斯，使用了一种口服避孕丸，非常像我们今天含有人工合成孕激素的那些，这些孕激素是由一家制药公司提供的。他们在一项被称为生育研究的项目中将其施用于50名女性，因为在当时20世纪50年代，也就是甚至不到100年前，甚至不到100年前，避孕在美国的大部分地区（包括马萨诸塞州）都是非法的。所以他们不得不以实际上试图帮助女性怀孕为幌子来开展这项研究，而不是为了赋予女性不这样做的权力。因此，女性连续21天服用这种药丸，随后休息七天，他们得出的结论是，在
women during drug administration, basically meaning that when these women were taking this artificial steroid, they could not fall pregnant. So one of these scientists, they wrote a scientific research paper and explained how this drug succeeded in inhibiting ovulation, but skepticism kind of remained in authorities. At the time, there was, I guess, a lot of rhetoric around whether women should be able to control whether they wanted to give birth, especially considering that the World War II had occurred only 10 years before, and there was a big push to increase population size and to have more children. So the introduction of something that would allow women to control whether or whether they didn't want to have children
药物施用期间，没有任何女性发生排卵，这基本上意味着当这些女性服用这种人工类固醇时，她们无法怀孕。因此，其中一位科学家撰写了一篇科学研究报告，解释了这种药物如何成功抑制排卵，但当局仍然抱有怀疑态度。在当时，我猜有很多关于女性是否应该能够控制自己是否想要生育的言论，特别是考虑到第二次世界大战仅仅在10年前发生，当时有一股巨大的推动力来增加人口规模和生育更多孩子。因此，引入某种可以让女性控制自己是否想要孩子的东西，
kind of stood in the way of that goal of increasing the size of the population of the US. But they pushed ahead, and in order to provide kind of further evidence that this daily pill was effective, they moved their studies to Puerto Rico to conduct a larger clinical trial. Now, there is a lot of ethical discussions around conducting medical trials in communities that may be less developed or have lower incomes than, say, more developed countries like the US. So it's believed that the reason they took their study here was because, A, it was cheaper to get participants. In some cases, they didn't even need to pay, they only needed to pay them a small amount. And there would be less kind of ethical and moral questions and questions from the government regarding their intent.
某种程度上阻碍了增加美国人口规模的目标。但他们继续推进，为了提供进一步的证据证明每日口服避孕丸是有效的，他们将研究转移到波多黎各进行更大规模的临床试验。现在，在发展程度较低或收入低于像美国这样更发达国家的社区中进行医学试验，存在着许多伦理讨论。因此人们认为他们把研究带到这里的原因是：A，招募参与者的成本更低。在某些情况下，他们甚至不需要付费，只需要支付少量费用。而且政府对他们意图的伦理、道德问题以及质疑也会更少。
Basically, they could do things that were a little bit more dangerous, knowing that no one would really care, other than the communities and their voices weren't loud enough to be heard on an international. scale. Luckily enough, the pill was reported to be successful, but, and this is a really crucial point for our later discussions, there were so many side effects for legal consideration and for medical consideration that the medical director of the clinical trials actually said that this should not be considered, that the hormonal birth control of the pill posed too many side effects and dangers for it to become more popular and prevalent. Instead, they forged ahead and after kind of conducting further clinical
基本上，他们可以做一些稍微危险一点的事情，因为他们知道没有人会真正在意，除非是那些社区，而他们的声音不够响亮，无法在国际范围内被听到。幸运的是，据报道避孕丸成功了，但是——这是我们以后讨论的一个至关重要的一点——有太多的副作用，出于法律和医学考虑，临床试验的医学主任实际上表示，这不应被考虑，因为避孕丸这种激素避孕方法带来了太多的副作用和危险，以至于无法变得更加流行和普及。相反，他们向前迈进，在进行了进一步的临床试验并降低了雌激素和孕激素的剂量后，这种由女性控制的避孕方法（现在被称为避孕丸）迅速在全国范围内投入使用，以防止怀孕。
trials and lowering the dosage of estrogen and progesterone, the female controlled contraceptive method, now known as the pill, became a rapid nationwide use for protection against pregnancy. And nowadays, and we know it is prescribed in its millions to people all over the world every year and is one of the most popular birth control methods for many of the reasons we've already stated. It is cheap. It is effective. It is within the women's control. But it's also important to remember those initial side effects that were brought up in those early clinical trials that initially caused people to be quite wary of the use of synthetic hormones to control our natural cycles. And this is kind of what I'm keen to discuss for the rest of this episode. Firstly,
如今，我们知道它每年被处方给世界各地数以百万计的人，并且由于我们已经说明的许多原因，它是最受欢迎的避孕方法之一。它很便宜。它很有效。它在女性的掌控之中。但同样重要的是，要记住那些在早期临床试验中提出的初始副作用，这些副作用最初让人对使用合成激素来控制我们的自然周期保持相当谨慎的态度。这也是我渴望在接下来的节目中讨论的内容。首先，
diving into some of the physical side effects and then, of course, moving on to the psychological impacts of regularly taking synthetic hormones and what that does for our mental well-being and the natural processes and cycles of our bodies. Okay, I'm going to make a bit of a disclaimer. And I'm going to make it early before we start talking about some of the side effects and impacts and influences that come with hormonal birth control, particularly the pill. Personally, I am not the biggest fan of this method of reproductive health or reproductive control. From my experience, I have found that the side effects greatly outweigh the benefits, and in some cases, some of the more serious side effects that are more common than you would
深入探讨一些身体副作用，然后，当然，转向定期服用合成激素对心理产生的影响，以及这会对我们的心理健康和身体的自然过程与周期产生什么影响。好吧，我要做一个免责声明。我要在开始讨论伴随激素类避孕药（特别是避孕丸）而来的一些副作用、影响和作用之前，尽早做出这个声明。就我个人而言，我并不是这种生殖健康或生殖控制方法的超级粉丝。根据我的经验，我发现副作用远远大于好处，而且在某些情况下，一些比你想象的要更常见的更严重的副作用，并不总是在你可能最初被开避孕药的医疗环境中或在医学背景下进行讨论，通常那是在很小的年龄。
probably think aren't always discussed in a medical environment or in a medical context when you might be first being prescribed the pill, often at an early age. But I also know it's a personal choice, and there are a number of amazing reasons for being on birth control, and family planning is just kind of one of them. So I think there is a misconception that people who take the pill take it for one reason. They're sexually active. They want to not fall pregnant. But it's really an amazing kind of technology and an amazing medicine for controlling things like endometriitis,
但我也知道这是一个个人选择，而且使用避孕药有许多极好的理由，计划生育只是其中之一。所以我认为存在一种误解，即认为服用避孕药的人只有一个原因。他们有性生活。他们不想怀孕。但这实际上是一项了不起的技术，也是一种了不起的药物，用于控制诸如子宫内膜异位症、
for controlling acne and regulating heavy or irregular periods that can cause things like anemia and iron deficiency. And there's also been some interesting studies that have shown that it can reduce the risk of uterine cancer and some other forms of preventable cancers that often are more prevalent in women. So birth control is not the only kind of function. Family planning is not the only function. It can have a lot of other impacts on our physical health and our well-being that often aren't
控制痤疮以及调节可导致贫血和缺铁的经量过多或经期不规律。还有一些有趣的研究表明，它还可以降低子宫癌以及女性更常见的一些其他形式的可预防癌症的风险。因此，避孕并不是唯一的职能。计划生育也不是唯一的职能。它对我们的身体健康和幸福感会产生许多其他的影响，而这些往往没有得到足够的讨论。这些都是使用合成激素的所有真正惊人的好处，不仅用于避孕，还用于身体健康和幸福感的其他要素。如果你有子宫内膜异位症或月经不调，你可能会考虑这一点。这是一种掌控自己健康的好方法，不仅是在决定何时组建家庭方面，而且是以更全面的方式思考你的健康。
discussed as much. And these are all some of the really amazing benefits of using synthetic hormones, not just for birth control, but for other elements of physical health and well-being. And it might be something that you would consider if you have endometriitis or a regular period. It's a great way to kind of take control over your health, not just in terms of deciding when you want to have a family, but thinking about your health and a more holistic. way. Though we kind of typically present hormonal contraceptives as a really great success for women,
方式。尽管我们通常将激素类避孕药表现为女性的一大巨大成功，
which they are, sometimes we do tend to overlook some of the serious side effects that have been reported in mainstream scientific literature. And I've often found that when you are initially being prescribed the pill, and this is obviously anecdotal, they're not always brought up, either through negligence or just because they're not seen as important. And women who do regularly ingest hormonal birth control methods, we'll find that they usually have a few side effects. Most of the time, they're common and they're manageable, but they can be more serious. And I'm sure we've all had friends who have told us stories about terrible episodes of depression or weight gain or mood swings, even stories about people who've had strokes or heart attacks
它们确实如此，但有时我们确实倾向于忽视主流科学文献中报道的一些严重副作用。我经常发现在你最初被开避孕药时——这显然是轶事——这些副作用并不总是被提出来，这可能是由于疏忽，也可能只是因为它们没有被视为重要。经常摄入激素类避孕方法的人会发现她们通常会有一些副作用。大多数时候，它们是常见且可控的，但也可能更严重。我确信我们都有过这样的朋友，他们向我们讲述了可怕的抑郁症发作、体重增加或情绪波动的经历，甚至有人中风或心脏病的经历，
because the interaction between, because increasing kind of hormonal, hormone levels, particularly through artificial methods, can really fuck with our bodies in some ways and interact with pre-existing conditions in a ways that can be quite dangerous. Some of the common kind of physical side effects that I think are pretty manageable, can be things like nausea and headaches, acne, decreased libido and weight gain. All of these, I think, are something that can be, brought into the equation of costs and benefits or risks and benefits that we kind of all personally have to do when we are considering birth control and family planning.
因为增加某种激素水平（特别是通过人工方法）的相互作用，在某些情况下真的会搞砸我们的身体，并以相当危险的方式与既往病症相互作用。我认为相当可控的一些常见的身体副作用可能是恶心和头痛、痤疮、性欲减退和体重增加。所有这些，我认为都可以被纳入我们在考虑避孕和计划生育时个人都必须做出的成本与效益或风险与效益的权衡方程式中。
Is, you know, weight gain, is a decreased libido, is acne, something that is worth it for you? And that's a completely personal choice. But there can be some more serious side effects that we don't discuss as much. And although they're not as common for those who do experience them, it can be pretty dangerous. Things like blood cuts, having heart attacks, high blood pressure, a stroke, there are even some cancers that there have been indications that increasing the synthetic level of hormones such as estrogen and progesterone in your body can contribute to, such as liver cancer. But these are all more likely to be the case with underlying conditions such as a
体重增加、性欲减退、痤疮，这些对你来说值得吗？这是一个完全个人的选择。但可能会有一些我们讨论较少的更严重副作用。尽管对于经历过的人来说它们没有那么常见，但可能会相当危险。像血栓、心脏病发作、高血压、中风，甚至有迹象表明增加体内雌激素和孕激素等合成激素水平可能会导致某些癌症，例如肝癌。但如果存在潜在病症，例如特定癌症和血液疾病（如莱顿因子V）的遗传倾向或家族史，这些情况更有可能发生，而这些在我们被开避孕药时通常不会进行检测，我自己的情况就是如此。因此，如果你确实有经历某些更严重副作用的倾向，那么在做出服用口服避孕药或服用避孕丸的决定之前，了解这一点并将其作为方程式的一部分真的很重要。而且通常这不是一个被考虑的因素。当你第一次被开这种药物时，也不是你的医生会提醒你的事情。因此，如果你目前正在使用激素类避孕药或正在考虑使用，我真的建议你让医生做一次血液检查，确保
predisposition or a family history of particular cancers and blood conditions like life. and factor five, which aren't often tested for when we are prescribed birth control, which was the case for myself. So if you do have a predisposition to perhaps experiencing some of the more serious side effects, it's really important that that is known and that is part of the equation before you make the decision to take oral contraceptives or to take the pill. And often it's not something that is factored in. And it's not something that your doctor alerts you to when you're first being prescribed this medication. So if you are on hormonal birth control at the moment or considering it, I would really suggest that you get your doctor to run a blood test, make sure that
你没有任何潜在病症，以免增加你经历某些更严重副作用（如血栓和中风）的可能性。还要考虑你处于什么剂量，避孕丸中含有越多的雌激素和孕激素，效果就会越高，但你也就更有可能出现我们讨论过的一些副作用。但这是一个心理学播客。所以让我们来讨论长期甚至短期使用避孕药的一些心理副作用。这就是我们今天真正想要回答的问题。避孕药和激素类避孕药是如此普遍，特别是在20多岁的女性当中，但这对于她们如何经历20多岁意味着什么？这对她们的心理前景、选择、行为和情绪健康意味着什么？
you don't have any underlying conditions that might increase your likelihood of experiencing some of those more serious side effects, like blood clots and like stroke. And also considering what dosage you're on, the more estrogen and progesterone that is in the pill, it will increase the effectiveness, but it's more likely that you will have some of those side effects that we've talked about. But this is a psychology podcast. So let's cover some of the psychological side effects of long-term and even short-term birth control use. That's the question we really wanted to answer today. Birth control and hormonal birth control is so common, particularly amongst women in their 20s. but what does that mean for how they experience their 20s and what does it mean for their psychological outlook, their choices, their behaviours and their emotional well-being?
所以我认为，口服避孕药和避孕方法对人类心理的长期影响在过去甚至现在都被严重低估了，直到最近才真正成为主流学者的关注焦点。特别是，我认为对于少数群体来说，他们往往没有被纳入这项研究，情况通常就是这样。总的来说，我认为这是一个相当普遍的共识，即与女性相关的健康问题获得的资金较少，研究兴趣较少，这会对激素类避孕药的处理方式以及这些药物的可获得性产生非常大的长期影响。研究发现，使用激素类避孕药的人与不使用的人相比，患抑郁症和焦虑症、疲劳、性障碍、强迫症、愤怒等问题的比率更高，所有这些都在某种程度上塑造了我们对生活的看法。
So I think the long-term impact of the oral contraceptive and birth control methods on human psychology has been vastly under-researched in the past and even in the current day and has really only recently become a focus for mainstream scholars. particularly, I think, for minority populations, they've often not been included in this research, as is often the case. And in general, I think it is a pretty common understanding that health issues related to women receive less funding, receive less research interest, and that can have a really big long-term impact on how things like hormonal birth control are treated and the availability of these medications. So hormonal contraceptive uses in contraceptive. contrast with non-users have been found to have high rates of things like depression and anxiety, fatigue, sexual disturbances, compulsion, anger, all of which kind of create our outlook on life.
这很合情理，你把某种人工的东西放进体内，它确实具有令人难以置信的好处，让你能够控制自己的身体，决定何时想要怀孕，它允许你控制我们之前讨论过的其他一些病症，如子宫内膜异位症或缺铁。但还有其他一些重要的研究表明，心理影响的深度往往并不为人所知，也没有像在医疗背景下那样得到应有的广泛分享。因此，在2016年9月，这家精神病学期刊发表了一项非常有趣的开创性丹麦研究，该研究发现使用激素类避孕药与被诊断出临床抑郁症之间存在相关性。这项研究追踪了激素类避孕药的使用情况，并
It makes sense you're putting something artificial into your body, and it does have incredible benefits that allows you to have control over your body over when you want to fall pregnant. it allows for you to have control over some of those other conditions we talked about like endometriitis or iron deficiency. But there are some other important studies that show that the depths of the psychological impact are often not well known and not shared as frequently in a medical context as they probably should be. So in September 2016, this psychiatry journal published a really interesting kind of ground baking Danish study that found a correlation between the use of hormonal birth control and being diagnosed with clinical depression. So this study attract hormonal birth control use and the
把你身体里的人工合成物质放进去是合乎逻辑的，它确实有惊人的好处，能让你控制自己的身体，决定何时怀孕。它能让你控制我们之前讨论过的其他一些疾病，比如子宫内膜异位症或缺铁。但还有其他一些重要研究表明，其心理影响的深度往往并不为人所熟知，在医疗背景下也往往没有像应有的那样被频繁分享。因此，在2016年9月，这家精神病学杂志发表了一项非常有趣的、具有突破性的丹麦研究，该研究发现使用荷尔蒙避孕药与被诊断出临床抑郁症之间存在相关性。所以这项研究追踪了荷尔蒙避孕药的使用情况，并
prescription of antidepressants over six years for over a million women. So this was not a small clinical study like some of those studies that initially led to the creation of the pill. That was over a million women. And they found the women who were on hormonal birth control, such as the pill were significantly more likely to be prescribed antidepressants compared to those who weren't taking or weren't using synthetic hormonal forms of birth control. And it found a particularly strong correlation between teenage birth control users and depression. So there was an 80% increased risk for teens taking birth control and their likelihood of starting antidepressants after going on the pill. And this is a really troubling statistic, especially because the pill is often prescribed when we are quite young, when we become sexually active or sometimes to treat acne or severe menstrual symptoms and just as a general preventative measure.
对超过一百万名女性进行了为期六年的抗抑郁药处方研究。所以这并不是一项小型的临床研究，就像当初促成避孕药问世的某些研究那样。那是针对一百万名女性的研究。他们发现，使用荷尔蒙避孕药（比如避孕药）的女性，被开具抗抑郁药的可能性明显高于那些没有服用或未使用合成荷尔蒙避孕形式的女性。研究还发现，处于青春期的避孕药使用者与抑郁症之间存在特别强的关联。因此，服用避孕药的青少年患抑郁症的风险增加了80%，并且在服用避孕药后开始使用抗抑郁药的可能性也增加了。这是一个非常令人不安的统计数据，尤其是因为避孕药通常在我们很年轻的时候就被开具，也就是当我们开始有性生活时，或者有时是为了治疗痤疮或严重的经期症状，以及仅仅作为一种常规的预防措施。
That's something to be considered. Depression is obviously a pretty serious mental condition. and it's interesting that taking this pill is or taking some form of hormonal birth control is increasing your likelihood of suffering through what can be and what is often a really traumatic and difficult mental health problem. I think the other thing that was often brought up, and there are kind of four other links that I wanted to make with psychology and taking hormonal birth control. And those are things like uncontrollable mood swings,
这是需要考虑的一点。抑郁症显然是一种相当严重的心理疾病，有趣的是，服用这种避孕药或某种形式的荷尔蒙避孕药会增加你经历这种可能是、而且往往是一种真正创伤性和困难的心理健康问题的可能性。我认为另一个经常被提及的问题是，我想把心理学与服用荷尔蒙避孕药联系起来的另外四种关系。这些就是诸如无法控制的情绪波动等情况，
We've talked about depression, changes in sleeping patterns, loss of libido and your sexual preferences and your sexual choices, all of which will have a pretty deep and profound impact on how you experience your 20s, how you go about living your daily life, your relationships with your partners, with your friends, with your family, and just with your general overall experiences. So of all of the side effects of hormonal birth control, mood swings are often the most common. So it's pretty common to feel irritable or short-tempered, particularly around when your period might take place. And hormonal birth control makes those mood swings much worse to the point of, I know, crying for no reason, feeling a lot of guilt, feeling bad about yourself, having low self-esteem, and just a general kind of, sadness about the way that you're living your life. So up to 10% of women aren't actually able to tolerate synthetic progesterone as an ingredient in birth control because of this impact, because they do have uncontrollable mood swings that make it difficult to kind of function in their daily
我们已经讨论过抑郁症、睡眠模式的改变、性欲丧失、性偏好以及性选择，所有这些都会对你如何度过20多岁、如何过日常生活、你与伴侣、朋友、家人的关系以及你的一般整体体验产生深远的影响。因此，在荷尔蒙避孕药的所有副作用中，情绪波动往往是最常见的。因此，感到易怒或暴躁是非常普遍的，特别是在经期前后。而荷尔蒙避孕药会使这些情绪波动变得更加严重，甚至达到毫无理由地哭泣、感到内疚、对自己感觉不好、自卑，以及对生活方式普遍感到悲伤的程度。因此，高达10%的女性实际上无法耐受合成孕激素作为避孕药的成分，因为这种影响，因为她们有无法控制的情绪波动，这使得她们很难在日常生活中正常
life and decrease their well-being to the point that taking this easy form of birth control just isn't worth it for them anymore. Like I said, this is a personal choice. And that's only the case with 10% of women. Most women might not have this reaction. They might find that their side effects or some of the impacts are super minor and the benefits of being able to control when they fall pregnant, of being able to control their likelihood of having a child or family planning. That is an amazing benefit and it's a really empowering benefit and it's worth it for them. I want to talk about depression a little bit more because that is perhaps one of the most serious side effects and one of the most common as well. In the days before your menstrual cycle
生活，并且降低了她们的幸福感，以至于服用这种简单的避孕方式对她们来说已经不值得了。就像我说的，这是一个个人选择。而且这只占女性的10%。大多数女性可能不会有这种反应。她们可能会发现自己的副作用或某些影响非常微小，而且能够控制怀孕时间、控制生育可能性或进行家庭规划的好处是巨大的。这是一个惊人的好处，是一个真正赋予赋能的好处，对她们来说是值得的。我想多谈谈抑郁症，因为这也许是最严重的副作用之一，也是最常见的副作用之一。在你的月经周期开始之前的几天
begins or before your period, it's pretty natural to have an emotional shift that's going to cause you to feel less confident about yourself, maybe emotionally sensitive, a bit moody. But when these symptoms change from uncomfortable feelings to depressive symptoms, such as an inability to get out of bed, feeling really unhappy about your life, significant appetite changes, significant changes to your motivation, significant changes to your capacity or your ability to reach out to family and friends and ask for support, that's probably a time and an indicator that you need to be concerned. Your overall functioning is not where it should be. Your 20s are meant to be a time of experiencing things and being happy with yourself and exploring things and trying new things out
或者在你的经期到来之前，情绪发生转变是相当自然的，这会让你对自己的自信心下降，也许在情感上很敏感，有点喜怒无常。但是，当这些症状从不舒服的感觉转变为抑郁症状时，比如无法起床、对生活感到非常不快乐、胃口发生显著变化、动力发生显著变化、联系家人和朋友并寻求支持的能力或容量发生显著变化，这可能是一个需要关注的时间和指标。你的整体功能没有达到应有的水平。你的20多岁本应是体验事物、对自己感到满意、探索事物并尝试新事物的一段时光
and getting out there and making friends and being social before you have some of those responsibilities that come along with later life. But research measuring the clinical impact of oral contraceptives, like I said, it found that women taking the pill are more likely to suffer from depression than non-pill users. And women using birth control with particularly large amounts of estrogen had more instances of depression than those who are on a lower dosage. So perhaps that's something that needs to be questioned. Is it worth prescribing women birth control pills and the pill that have large amounts of this synthetic hormone that we know can really increase their risk of pretty serious side effects? Studies have also shown that
并在承担晚年生活的某些责任之前，走出去结交朋友并进行社交。但研究口服避孕药临床影响的研究正如我所说，发现服用避孕药的女性比不服用避孕药的女性更容易患上抑郁症。而且使用雌激素含量特别高的避孕药的女性，其抑郁症发作的次数多于使用较低剂量的女性。所以也许这是一个需要质疑的问题。给女性开具含有大量这种合成荷尔蒙的避孕药是否值得，我们知道这确实会增加她们患相当严重副作用的风险？研究还表明，
women with a history of depression, depressive symptoms, it can be made more. worse when they're on birth control. So I think if you have a history of depression, you feel a significant change in your emotions leading up to your period to the point of severe impacts on your functioning, maybe even thoughts of self-harm, really low confidence. It's important to speak to your doctor about alternative birth control methods. The pill is really easy. Like I said, it's often prescribed early and really frequently. But when we come to things, think about these psychological impacts that will bleed on to the rest of your life. Perhaps it is important to consider non-hormonal birth control methods or those that aren't
有过抑郁症病史、抑郁症状的女性，在使用避孕药时可能会加重病情。所以我想，如果你有抑郁症病史，你感觉到经期前的情绪发生了显著变化，以至于严重影响了你的功能，甚至有自残的念头、自信心非常低。向你的医生咨询替代的避孕方法是很重要的。避孕药真的很简单。就像我说的，它经常被很早且非常频繁地开具。但当我们考虑到这些将蔓延到你其余人生的心理影响时，也许考虑非荷尔蒙避孕方法或那些不那么依赖雌激素来控制周期的避孕方法是很重要的。
as reliant on estrogen to kind of control your cycle. There are some other things that are really important to consider that link to our psychology in our 20s and that's changes in sleeping patterns and a loss of libido. So it's really normal to have an off day here and there where you feel like you just want to sleep in, you can't get to sleep, maybe you're experiencing insomnia, But if you feel like this every day, it could be that your birth control is affecting your sleeping patterns. Often it's birth control that contains progesterone that can lead you to experiencing either
还有一些其他非常重要的事情需要考虑，它们与我们20多岁的心理学息息相关，那就是睡眠模式的改变和性欲的丧失。所以偶尔有一两天感觉不在状态，只想赖床、睡不着觉，或者可能正在经历失眠，这其实是很正常的，但如果你每天都有这种感觉，那可能是你的避孕药在影响你的睡眠模式。通常是含有孕激素的避孕药会导致你经历极端失眠
extreme insomnia or extreme fatigue. And one of the other symptoms that I think is talked about a lot, but it's important to be considered in a more nuanced light, is a loss of libido. Let's be honest, most of us go on hormonal birth control because we want to have sex and we want to enjoy the sex that we're having. Maybe you first considered it when you had, you know, your first long-term partner, or you were becoming sexually active with someone who could, you know, make you fall pregnant. And I guess if that's the, that's the reason why you go on hormonal birth control, you probably want to be able to have sex after you're on it. But birth control has been
或是极度的疲劳。我认为被讨论得很多、但需要在更细致的视角下去考虑的另一个症状是性欲丧失。老实说，我们大多数人使用荷尔蒙避孕药是因为我们想过性生活，而且想享受我们正在进行的性生活。也许你第一次考虑它时，你有了第一个长期伴侣，或者你开始与一个可能让你怀孕的人有性行为。我想如果这就是你使用荷尔蒙避孕药的原因，你可能希望在使用它之后还能过性生活。但避孕药已经被
found to kind of reduce sexual desire in women. So most combined birth control pills, which are the most common. They contain estrogen and progesterone, which we have talked about. And these hormones tinker with the way your body works. Many of these combined pills actually lower your testosterone levels relative to your estrogen levels. And testosterone is the hormone that makes you want to have sex. We generally think of it as a male hormone, but women also have it just not as much. And it's really important for controlling sexual desire and controlling kind of energy levels, levels of kind of passion and emotion. But if the pill kind of interrupts the kind of production of testosterone, which ignites sexual desire, you might start to see that you do have
发现会降低女性的性欲。因此，大多数复合避孕药是最常见的。它们含有我们讨论过的雌激素和孕激素。这些荷尔蒙会干扰你身体的运作方式。许多这种复合避孕药实际上会降低你的睾酮水平相对于雌激素水平。而睾酮是让你产生性欲的荷尔蒙。我们通常认为它是男性荷尔蒙，但女性也有，只是没有那么多。它对于控制性欲和控制能量水平、激情和情感水平非常重要。但是，如果避孕药干扰了点燃性欲的睾酮的产生，你可能会开始发现你确实拥有
lower levels of sexual desire. That can have an impact on your relationship. Obviously, choosing to have sex and when you want to have sex is completely up to you and should always be consensual. But in committed relationship, sex is often a really important, element of the relationship and it's part of the discussions that we have to have with our partner. So seeing a dramatic change in the amount that you might want to be sexually active with your partner or be intimate with them can really impact the state of your relationship and can lead to perhaps some difficult discussions. Women who use birth control, particularly hormonal birth control, I would like to say things like condoms obviously are external. They don't really
较低的性欲水平。这会对你的关系产生影响。很明显，选择何时发生性行为完全取决于你，并且应该始终是自愿的。但在坚定的恋爱关系中，性往往是关系中非常重要的一个元素，它是我们必须与伴侣进行的讨论的一部分。因此，看到你可能希望与伴侣发生性行为或与他们亲密的频率发生戏剧性的变化，确实会影响你的关系状态，并可能导致一些艰难的讨论。使用避孕药的女性，特别是荷尔蒙避孕药——我想说像避孕套显然是外用的。它们并没有真正
impact on the internal functioning of our body. Same with the copper IUD, which isn't hormonally based. But hormonal birth control methods have been linked to, like I said, reduced sexual functioning, but also a high interest in short-term sexual relationships compared to naturally kind of cycling counterparts. And some evidence even suggests that birth control use might even alter your mate choice and may negatively affect sexual satisfaction in women who are choosing to have sex with men. And that has really important impacts on who you choose to date, the kind of sex you choose to have. And I don't think it's perhaps a negative thing, but it's just something to be considered and also really interesting when we think that we think about the relationship
影响我们身体内部的运作。铜IUD也是如此，它不是基于荷尔蒙的。但正如我所说，荷尔蒙避孕方法与降低的性功能有关，而且与自然周期的同龄人相比，对短期性关系的兴趣也更高。一些证据甚至表明，避孕药的使用甚至可能会改变你的伴侣选择，并可能对选择与男性发生性关系的女性的性满意度产生负面影响。这对于你选择与谁约会、选择进行什么样的性行为有着非常重要的影响。我不认为这可能是一件消极的事情，但这只是一件需要考虑的事情，而且当我们想到增加体内这些荷尔蒙水平与我们选择谁作为伴侣之间的关系时，这也是非常有趣的，
between increasing the level of these hormones in our body and who we choose as a mate. or who we choose as a partner or who we choose to have sex with. Yeah, something to be considered. I don't think that's necessarily a negative thing, but it's just a really interesting finding, and I think kind of highlights that deeper interaction I'm trying to paint a picture of, which is that taking the pill is not a passive decision. It does actually have huge, huge impacts on how we go about our lives in our 20s.
或者我们选择谁作为伴侣，或者我们选择与谁发生性行为。是的，这是一件需要考虑的事情。我不认为这必然是一件消极的事情，但这只是一个非常有趣的发现，我认为它突显了我试图描绘的更深层次的互动，那就是服用避孕药并不是一个被动的决定。它实际上对我们20多岁的生活方式产生了巨大、巨大的影响。
And whenever you're taking hormonal birth control, the choices we choose to make, our outlook, our mental well-being. I would like to say, just because there have been links between hormonal birth control and mental health issues and other psychological side effects, that doesn't mean that birth control will have the same impact on everyone using it. I think these can be particular cases and often making the decision to lower your dose or to perhaps try a different method. Like I said, non-hormonal birth control methods like natural family planning or the copper IUD or condoms.
无论何时你服用荷尔蒙避孕药，我们做出的选择、我们的观点、我们的心理健康。我想说，仅仅因为荷尔蒙避孕药与心理健康问题和其他心理副作用之间存在联系，并不意味着避孕药会对每个使用者产生相同的影响。我认为这些可能是个别情况，通常做出的决定是降低剂量或者尝试不同的方法。就像我说的，非荷尔蒙避孕方法，比如自然家庭规划法、铜IUD或避孕套。
That just might be a personal and conscious choice that you have to make if that equation and if that kind of calculation of the cost versus the benefits of hormonal birth control maybe is leaning more towards the cost and more towards the risks. Thank you for tuning into this episode. This was a really interesting discussion for me, and hopefully it has been nuanced, and I've been able to kind of represent all perspectives. But I think at the end of the day,
如果这种等式以及荷尔蒙避孕药的成本与效益的计算可能更偏向于成本和风险，那可能就是你必须做出的个人和有意识的选择。感谢收听本期节目。对我来说，这是一场非常有趣的讨论，希望它是细致入微的，并且我能够代表所有的观点。但我认为归根结底，
the conclusion that I kind of made when I was researching this and when I was discussing this is that hormonal birth control, although it might be common and prevalent, is not always the simplest and easiest way of kind of controlling our reproductive system, and it's not the simplest, easiest way of birth control. There are heaps of considerations that we need to account for, especially around our psychological well-being, and the interactions that increasing the level of hormones like progesterone and estrogen
我在研究和讨论时得出的结论是，荷尔蒙避孕药虽然可能很常见和普遍，但并不总是控制我们生殖系统最简单、最容易的方法，也不是最简单、最容易的避孕方式。我们需要考虑很多因素，特别是围绕我们的心理健康，以及增加孕激素和雌激素等荷尔蒙水平的相互作用
has on our mental well-being and our emotional well-being, how we process emotions, how we see the world, even our experience of pretty intense and severe and significant mental health conditions like depression. So if this has been something that's been on your mind, I would really advocate for you going to your doctor to discuss it with them and doing your research, having the facts and keeping kind of a log of what the impact has been on you and why you think it might be important for you to perhaps consider an alternative method or maybe your birth. control is going fine. And you know what? Congratulations. That is amazing. You should be able to be empowered and have, I'll be able to make the decision over when you want to fall pregnant, if you want to fall pregnant, if you want to start a family, when you want to start a family. And I think that is just one of the amazing benefits of this technology that, like I said, has only really become
对我们的心理健康和情绪健康、我们如何处理情绪、我们如何看待世界，甚至是我们对像抑郁症这样相当强烈、严重和显著的心理健康状况的体验。所以如果这一直是您心头的一桩事，我真的非常倡导您去看医生并与他们讨论，做好研究，掌握事实，并记录下它对您的影响，以及为什么您认为考虑替代方法可能对您很重要，或者也许您的避孕药进行得很顺利。你知道吗？恭喜你。这太棒了。你应该能够获得赋能，并且能够自主决定何时想要怀孕、是否想要怀孕、是否想要组建家庭、何时想要组建家庭。我认为这正是这项技术的惊人好处之一，正如我所说，它真正变得
available in the last 60 years. And it really has changed the landscape for women's rights and the rights of those with the vagina around how they want to use their bodies and how they want their bodies to be treated. So yeah, a really, really interesting, historically based topic on the podcast this week. I really hope you enjoyed it. There will be some resources in the description of this episode. If you want to do some further research and have a look at some of the sources that I looked at, I tried to get a nice balance so that there were different perspectives being represented. But yeah, really interesting. And thank you again for listening. If you feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Spotify or Apple Podcasts or wherever you are listening to this episode right now. And if you feel cool to do so, we do also have a new subscriber network. So you can subscribe on Spotify and receive access to bonus content like Let's Get Friendly episodes and guest episodes. I'm just kind of trialing it at the moment, but it has been really amazing seeing how many people have gotten behind it.
在过去的60年里才真正变得可用。它确实改变了女性权利以及阴蒂所有者对如何使用自己的身体以及如何对待自己的身体的格局。所以，本周播客中这是一个非常非常有趣、具有历史基础的话题。我真的希望你喜欢。本期节目的描述中将有一些资源。如果你想做进一步的研究并查看我查看过的一些来源，我试图获得一个不错的平衡，以便代表不同的观点。但是，是的，真的很有趣。再次感谢您的倾听。如果您觉得很酷的话，请随时在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或您现在收听本期节目的任何地方留下五星评价。如果您觉得可以的话，我们确实还有一个新的订阅网络。因此，您可以在Spotify上订阅并获得访问奖励内容的权限，例如Let's Get Friendly剧集和嘉宾剧集。我目前只是在试用它，但看到有这么多人支持它，真的很惊人。
And it really allows me to do some of that content that's a bit more casual and a bit more personal, but so make it available to people to listen to it if they are interested. So thank you again. And hopefully I will see you back next week when we're going to be discussing the idea of soulmates and twin flames. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
它确实让我能够制作一些更休闲、更个性化的内容，但如果人们感兴趣的话，也可以让他们收听。再次感谢。希望下周还能见到你，届时我们将讨论灵魂伴侣和双生火焰的概念。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对后果。在
I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健康和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的《TWO percent》。这是一个IHeart播客，保证由人类制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。